in the throes of unrest a nation looking
for healing didn't get it here instead
the president focused on punishment in
the middle of a pandemic we will be
today terminating our relationship with
the World Health Organization and
redirecting those funds to other
worldwide and deserving urgent global
public health needs he left without a
single word on Minnesota as his 2020
rival called for an end to the quiet
bystander we're a country with an open
wound none of us can turn away none of
us can be silent none of us can any
longer can we hear the words I can't
breathe
and do nothing Minnesota burned as the
country raged at the death of yet
another african-american man in police
custody
fireworks looting and then a
presidential hand grenade these thugs
Donald Trump tweeted a diss honoring the
memory of George Floyd and I won't let
that happen
just spoke to Governor Tim waltz and
told him that the military is with him
all the way any difficulty and we will
assume control but when the looting
starts the shooting starts thank you he
now claims that was a statement of fact
not a threat Twitter declared it
violated its rules on glorifying
violence this is a scene here playing
out in Minneapolis is the first and not
the only in this story listen now is
this black CNN reporter covers it at the
fire department or with the fire
department department I should say on
that building we showed you there was
burning why why am i under arrest
he clearly identifies himself office to
move
okay but without explanation police
arrest him live on it this was the
arrest that ignited everything George
Floyd died after Derek Chauvin pinned
him to the ground and put his knee on
his neck he has now been charged with
third-degree murder and manslaughter
there could be more to come for the
three other officers involved without
justice there will be little to calm
this city even less to console
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Washington